[Music]
the celebration over Jota copies
history-making promotion being part of
the first female led team on The Today
Show has taken a turn and so many are
now infuriated well here's why despite
the fact that she will be doing two jobs
right - yes she will be Jota will
apparently make less than half of what
Matt Lauer used to take home why would
the show do that and does Hodapp plans
to shake things up we have the answers
welcome today thanks for joining us on
this Wednesday morning while Hoda Kotb
keeps the ship on course there's a
startling report about her new paycheck
the New York Post says the copy will
make 18 million dollars less than her
predecessor Matt Lauer copy salary
reportedly matches co-host Savannah
Guthrie's at 7 million that's less than
a third of Lauer's 25 million dollar a
year deal an NBC source points out that
Lauer did however work on the show for
25 years
still keep in mind that in addition to
the first two hours of today copy will
continue to co-host the fourth hour of
The Today Show with Kathie Lee Gifford
Jenna Bush Hager filled in for Gifford
this morning Kotb tells the magazine out
Friday I'm not making Matt Lauer money
not even close
a spokesperson tells et NBC doesn't
comment on compensation when something
feels right you just know Hoda told us
the new job felt like it was meant to be
and as for her salary negotiations well
despite that reported disparity there
appears to have been little drama and
then yeah then I think it was it was all
just you know the the stuff that you
have to do to make contracts work but it
was one of those things that had just
felt natural
and do not forget that there is no rest
for Hoda when she gets home the baby
girl she adopted last year Haleigh joy
is just under a year old for me that
means the no sleep zone